o le relève pas du parc naturel c'est
valoriser le patrimoine naturel et
culturel
nous sommes basés à saint pierre pour
valoriser que le nord qui est un peu on
va dire remettre au goût du jour y
compris saint pierre met en lumière
saint pierre les complets le nord aussi
et enfin mettre leur l'appeler mon
humour et les communes avoisinantes
qu'est ce que vous proposez aux
visiteurs en cinq ans nous proposons
visiteurs déjà c'est une visite de saint
pierre en outre open qui est
très très valorisant pour cette guerre
qui s'appelle le parc aux autorités
c'est un haut taux plein j'ai un petit
stylo que j'allume que je clique sur les
images alors j'ai ainsi aucune
orientation du sud
et par exemple je choisis et il y à
d'autres choses au sein de l'antenne
alors nous avons aussi une salle de
projection une salle de projection avec
deux films proposés à la matière du nas
un ski qui dure du 15 minutes
qui est qui a été réalisé par patrick
chamoiseau et nous avons
hommage à saint pierre c'est un film
d'une durée d'une heure qui parle
exactement de l'éruption des jours
précédents de l'appeler sinon dans
l'autre hall est toujours vous pouvez
trouver des produits les communiqués
comme du miel
nous avons mis en valeur
nos artisans locaux des associations ou
revendant leurs grilles vous pouvez
mettre de la lecture des confitures du
lot mais voilà quoi